[Music]
welcome back to new rockstars the book
of boba fett has been taking us around
the star wars universe to check in with
some familiar faces but we are wondering
if we're ever going to get to see boba
fett again in his own show and when is
the book going to show up already is
there when's the where's the book is it
overdue at the library someone get boba
a kindle already jesus christ it's 2021
or actually no it's a long time ago so i
don't think the technology has advanced
for kendall's anyway this is rogue
theory the show where we pitch the
wildest theories for the nerdy titles
that we love my name is md and going
with me today is the daimyo of my heart
it's jessica clemens what's going on
jess hi
not much just john you know
feeling it
just chilling oh you know sorry my cat
just bit my fingers
oh i think you get cat superpowers yes
now scratch yeah
spiderman logic there you go we're now
catwoman i'm scared i'm scared now i'm
gonna keep my hands over here and the
leader of the mod squad here at new
rockstars it is whitney van landingham
what's going on girl i have so many
cybernetic parts it's great all of them
are
i'm just robot underneath this
delightful cow shirt insane honestly
that's why we vibe it's like my heart
it's just a robot heart yeah it's cold
cold it's empty full of wine
empty a little electrifying too
hey
nice
and finally the marshall of this here
territory and the host of the film lost
first podcast it's eddie villanueva
what's going on what is up guys i am so
excited to talk about this i know we've
all been watching these episodes and
theories have just been coming up every
time i see these so i can't wait to talk
about them and uh yeah you guys are
robots mobots mod robots mobots
my butts
i'll be a mob mob bots mob bots there
you go
cause you be mobbing uh but hey before
we dive into all this star wars modbots
goodness a quick reminder that new
rockstars is going to be live in chicago
next week february 11th you can see eric
voss jessica clemons who is right here
phillip molina and tom mcbechtold live
as part of the very normal podcast tour
hosted by our partners at rooster teeth
it's going to be an awesome experience
full of fun surprises so if you live in
the chicago area come check us out at 8
pm at talia hall there's a ticket link
in the description and we'd love to see
you there to hang out and be nerds
together and have fun we like to have
fun here you guys like fun come on down
to chicago you live
in i lost australia by a plane get your
ass to chicago you sound like a relative
who's trying to get me to get excited to
do yard work yeah you're like fun go
grab a shovel we're gonna go dig holes
see i think people don't want to see the
show now
oh my god anyway um here we go um but
anyway the book of boba fett has been
our first big series of 2022 and it's
feeling like a good year guys it's
feeling good i'm feeling good about it
because book of boba fett's been pretty
good and next week is the final episode
and nobody was quite sure what this show
was going to be about and the last two
episodes have certainly surprised a lot
of people with all the character cameos
that they've had on the show but that
leads us to our first topic today
how will the book of boba fett end
because with the final episode of the
book of boba fett coming next week how
do you guys think all of these story
lines will tie up like will there be an
outcome for the planet of tatooine as we
leave the series and head into a year
full of new shows set in the star wars
universe what's gonna go down will boba
fett even be in the last episode of boba
fett
that is true
i don't i don't know hey
it's two thirds boba two-thirds mando it
it makes for a good drink so i mean hey
you know they actually just bring heart
low back
they bring ron solo back dude and then
they're like you know what no
they would have to drug harrison ford
and just drag his stoned carcass onto
set to get him to do a star war again
they're gonna do what futurama did with
larry bird and they're just gonna have
his likeness there and then have like
some voicemail saying audio don't book
me in your goddamn show i don't want to
be a part of that i'm doing a dog movie
now haven't you seen it it did really
well in box office
i think i think one of the one of the
ways that i would like to see because
ever since uh we got these last two
episodes there's been so many
introductions of people that we used to
know and love
in you know whatever show whatever
fashion it was whether it is clone wars
whether it's rebels whether if it was
you know
whatever effort in this last episode we
got a really great introduction of you
know spoiler alert you know one of the
most well-known bounty hunters and
assassins from the clone wars saga and
that's
cat bane so
knowing that we have such unique
individuals brought by the the star wars
love child of dave filoni um
i would like to see because of the fact
that we still have uh black
chrysanthemum in this show even though
it's been a couple episodes since we've
seen him
um
i would like to see the resolution of
this go in two ways number one uh we see
because of black chrysanthemum we see
dr aphra show up last minute with a
bunch of killer oh my god yes i've been
waiting for this and dr aphra so cool
and i feel like with with the direction
of everything i feel like luke and grogu
are gonna come to an agreement and luke
is gonna go help grogu
fight on their side and then they're
going to
uh they're gonna essentially help and
then groggy's gonna pretty much swear
off seeing the mando ever again my whole
thing about the jedi's coming into this
i think it's gonna be ahsoka tano i
don't think that uh luke and groger are
gonna come back because this is such a
small matter for luke luke does not feel
we also need to remember i i said this
to a bunch of people luke is pretty
freaking arrogant at this age this is
not older luke this is younger luke this
is arrogant younger look we saw how he
was telling grogu that he should he
might as well just choose being a jedi
over mandalorian because they suck like
the the speech he gave was already like
one-sided so i think luke is gonna and
he recognizes that like we have to have
a balance here if we go too far on one
end we're gonna turn evil if we go too
much on the other end we're still gonna
be evil so it's like there has to be a
balance i think this is one of those
worlds where luke is like this doesn't
have anything to really do with us so
i'm not gonna intervene there's bigger
things in the universe than this the
biggest reason just why because i was
thinking about that too as well like
with ahsoka being having that little
cameo in the show the last episode
i feel like the only reason why i say
luke is because the only reason is
because it's tattooing that's it yeah
you're right 100 because you find luke
becoming more wise towards the tail end
of his life
um as we've seen with the the sequel
trilogy however the only reason why i
would say there would be any tie is
because you know hometown pride that's
the only reason why i would say that's
the only well and that and that's i
could see him coming back for that but
it's also i okay so i could see him come
back for tattooing but it's a matter of
like is spice really that big of a deal
to come back to tatooine yeah um yeah i
feel like luke doesn't really give a
[ __ ] about like drug dealers and groggy
does
so i don't know
really cares who cares
cares about it
yeah
and the big big brother's little little
brother whatever program that was my
that was my sponsor it was growing yeah
little brothers big brothers little
brothers
but i i i'm on board with what eddie is
saying also because
it's the last episode right that's
coming so how are you going to bring in
cad bane
on the very almost last episode there
and he was such a big part of clone wars
that i think he's going to become it's
just this is just going forward it's
like they're not going to win because
we're gonna see cad bane more also i'm
sure that even though the deputy is dead
um from that episode uh timothy oliphant
is just injured but he's gonna come back
again they're setting it up so we get
clearly more
people in the next season versus it
actually
ending well now
so marshall cobb vance yeah marshall cup
which i was like boy you don't have a
uniform and even caught and even uh
cad bane said that baby
shot in the crotch so it bounces off of
his marshall
his marshall stripes
keeps his
do you know how important a belt is i'm
like i guess i didn't in space in
western space it's that
that naval protector right there it's
the naval protector
i'm never gonna get shot in the stomach
oh i got shot in the chest
yeah it's like yo remember that weird
time in like the 2000s where everyone
had those huge that's what it is that's
what it is like
he just has a best scar
you because we live belly it do you know
how much money that's our bell belt
buckle best balls belt buckles
it's really hard to say fast garbage i
love that cat
boy
belt buckles belt buckle
like you should have kept that armor
because i'm about to shoot you a
chest cad bane
best thing that happened to star wars in
my opinion because i love villains but i
also love bounty hunters and the bounty
hunter that trained j or the bounty
hunter that was trained by jango fett
that changed that train to boba fett
what better person is there in the star
wars legacy than that exactly i
seriously think he might be like the
smartest person in star wars too because
not only has he already figured out a
way to bypass himself ever getting covet
19. uh he also has stopped people from
being able to force choke him which like
that is the most clutch skill in the
star wars universe to like not be able
to force choke someone the fact that he
figured out how to do that like holy
[ __ ]
he figured out a way to to break into
the jedi temple yeah i mean if you go
back to you know the clone wars song
figured out a way to do all that [ __ ]
i'm i'm the only hiccup i have is i i
swear to god that seth green robot
better not show up again
from the clone wars why do you hate him
because
it's like
i loved him i was so into it and i was
like i hope it shows up for some reason
i loved cad bane in the clone wars but i
was like oh he just looks like okay it's
great but seeing the cgi of him in this
episode of the book of boba fett i said
wrap me up in a bow shove my knee in his
mouth
i said i don't care they brought him
into the star wars they finally brought
him in and it's the same guy that voice
act him in the clone wars
god okay i'm i love him he is the best i
thought i loved general grievous but it
was cad vain
don't remind you like you take you take
the intellectual prowess of what cad
bain has done in the clone wars saga you
know and you look at that entire swath
of everything he's capable of he's
outsmarted jedi he's outsmarted you know
local authorities he's outsmarted even
you know empire uh individuals i mean he
is and he's lasted as long as
yeah
and he's lasted as long as this
from the clone wars to this time after
return of the jedi like he's been able
to survive
so
you know what that's badass like what i
just thought
i don't know how this made me think of
this eddie but the how the book of boba
fett will end i think
call me call me crazy
do you think we'll get a ben solo
eventually by
a kylo ren eventually soon soon and
maybe in the next season when they're
finished building the jedi school do you
think we'll start like we could see a
young han solo they could cgi him in i
just don't know if he even let them
are you thinking of the timeline mt yeah
i think that we're we we would likely
see a young poe dameron because i think
during this time
poe dameron's parents are this is this
is what i want
i want to see an introduction of mara
at the tail end of this mara jade oh my
god i want to see something
i'm thinking freak out i want to see
because we're talking about future
you know star wars shows and all that
they're digging into a lot of what's
legend and what's been now made canon
and there's that part of this story that
we haven't seen and then there's a whole
nother section that star wars is is is
kind of projecting about what to do in
terms of series-wise and if we're going
in the direction that they think they're
going
it'd be great to see
all those years in between
and quite possibly little things of
hints from those uh legacy
storylines that we knew and loved and
one of those things is i want to know
just like they did in the clone wars and
we talked about that uh with uh obi-wan
and the mandalorian uh satin oh sateen
sateen you're right but like if we're
gonna get that little hint in the clone
wars storyline
i'd love to see little hints of
luke being human as opposed to a jedi
you know
and this is one of those things that
would be really cool to kind of hint
towards like some local that happens to
wander around on that planet and they
see luke and she looks at him and and he
goes hey mara and then fades to black
like that would be insane
absolutely they opened the door for
everything for the final episode now
that they brought all these people back
but it's like is it too much to bring
more people in
but yeah
finale never too much more cabinets i
want the avengers here on tattoo star
wars is so big you could just do 900
cameos and the fans would just
wow do you want to wait anyways
helping
yeah yeah
he comes out wolverine goes out they'd
be like first off yeah what the what
cyborg are you are you a droid
are you a droid
are you feminine it's just the guardians
of the galaxy they died two minutes on
tattooing they last like literally two
minutes chris pratt goes down hard
that's what i want to see i want to see
that crossover
we need a ryan reynolds cameo that's
what we need deadpool just jumps out of
nowhere absolutely deadpool just showed
up yeah deadpool
deadpool and star wars he's like i went
to space once
oh that was a good impression it was
pretty that was a good impression oh
wait i liked it but what you got for us
how do you think about bookable vets
going in okay well i'm going to talk
about the obvious real quick just
because i want to talk about grogu
because i like him um but he's a cute i
think he's gonna go home with his mommy
i think he's gonna go home with the mom
delorean and he's gonna be like you luke
and your stupid ass yoga [ __ ] parkour
was cool but nothing else you shot me
with a laser ball and made me relive my
trauma and i did not ask for that uh
so i think that he's gonna gtfo back to
the mom delorean who loves him and we'll
cuddle him and kiss him and put a little
bus guard train mail on his little tiny
body that little chainmail hat that
little chainmail outfit i said put it on
him now i gotta get one for pugsley i
wanna make pugsley best car steal i
wanna make pugsley bulletproof yes
blaster proof
same thing how many enemies does pugsley
have
if you ask him ever apparently in the
neighborhood
he needs the bulletproof vest the
mailman the pizza delivery guy hey he's
just keeping you safe okay that's just
love yeah he is he loves me he's sweet
he loves me as loud as he possibly can
oh
the best car outfit was so sick it was
so sick because the bag that he gave him
as a gift i was like
is it a bracelet like because it was so
small i was like what do you ordered it
on etsy he said i had to wait three to
four weeks for it to come in
i had to wait for you sorry
the armor has her own etsy shop by the
way guys you can find her online yeah
i'm sure i saw her she makes great stuff
very very long-lasting when i was
looking into
a dreidel should they made a dress a
best guard dreidel
yeah endorse it right now
um i think they uh what was it it was
the
um
[Music]
the um oh the admiral
so timothy elephant the marshall has his
like that belt buckle and i was looking
into that belt buckle because i was like
i need to learn more about these three
lines because he's really obsessed with
these stripes at the very beginning it's
like the first thing he says and there's
so many etsy shops for the like uh that
the marshall badge in star wars uh just
and i was like as soon as this episode
drops at official time i know damn well
they're going to make that belt buckle
everyone's going to have that the
marshall has an etsy the army has an
etsy this is amazing
the whole etsy aspect
what if the last episode
is still them setting up sorry just go
back the last episode could still be
them setting up for the war still
setting up for the like because the we
end the episode with them going into the
bar and then exploding it so it's like
it doesn't mean that the war officially
started it could be that they're getting
ready if you guys know gang violence
which is star wars uh you know that they
get ready
exploding and yeah if you guys know have
you guys watched uh static shock lately
a lot of gang violence in that
but it is literally just i saw the
episode of the of the ish the gun
shooting at school that was a good
episode today it was a good evening that
was a
nuts episode bro that was like oh i
can't even believe that you're doing
this oh my god no but that's
that's actually a really interesting
idea jess cause you you take everything
that star wars does and they always
leave you wanting more i mean take a
look at the way these episodes have
ended i mean this last left us on a huge
cliffhanger and we're like what the
totally aunt maying this and so we were
it wouldn't surprise me if the war
doesn't start by the end of this thing
but something big does happen and you
know what would be interesting is if at
the end of the episode
you see fennick shad
dying
right before the world begins she needs
to die
not in a way of like i want her to die
but that character dying would change a
lot in the story and that story would be
really good if she cuz she already got
shot in the chest rebuilt now she
actually dies boba would literally have
no one so except for that creature in
the basement but
except for the creature in the basement
and um
danny trey and danny drake
you take away that two-person tribe and
boba fett just pretty much reverts back
to
who he used to be i think that's a good
pitch i think that's a really good pitch
i think she will be the one that dies
fenik oh my god it'll be i'll be so mad
but that's a good one and you also have
to consider now too that like all of
these like outliers who he met with
earlier when they were like he was like
explaining the d game that he wanted to
play with them and they were like we
don't want to do that campaign that
sounds way too complicated uh now now
that the bar exploded he's gonna have a
lot more people
kind of clamoring to be on his side i
think i guess boba could die
yeah and i don't know
please please please help that come true
i want them to do a season called the
book of boba fett where a book never
shows up there is never nary a book in
sight and then he is only in four
episodes and then dies
in the seasons
the next season is just a marker through
the word the words boba fetts the book
of finnick show the book yeah exactly
that's i think that's a great pitch i
think fennick is probably gonna die yeah
that'd be bananas if she died i'd be
very upset i don't want her to die
though because that actress so much i
want to see more of her interactions
with cad bane though because they have
such like i know that they have like the
rich history and all in any case i want
to see more than like half an episode
about
like they're i think cad bane's going to
be the one to shoot maximum toughness
chad is definitely going to be the one
to kill her and then he's going to go
yeah
and he's going to be like she was a
criminal
she was wanted yeah she was a criminal
getting like serious like serenity vibes
the whole thing is like boba fett's a
criminal he's just trying to stop other
criminals and cad said that to timothy
oliphant before he shot him in the chest
he said that's a criminal and he was
like yeah bane's only bashing people in
the chest baby that's why i love him and
so
it shoots people in that [ __ ]
that man does not [ __ ] like like the
the greatness of that introduction not
only solidifies the ruthlessness of cad
bane but also the intelligence because
yeah he knew what to say to get you know
uh the marshal so amped up without even
having to draw
the the uh the deputy was the one who
first drew cadbane just reacted and it's
like the man is just ruthless and he's
smart and those are two really dangerous
combinations you know and uh i just i
feel like yeah i feel like if she dies
if fennecian dies it's gonna be at the
hands of cad to be like this final final
threat you know i will take down
everything that you love
stop this war the pike's own tatooine
yeah cad has to eventually go down but i
just don't it's not going to be within
this season and he's either going to aim
for boba fett and fennick jumps in the
way or just straight shoot for fennec
and also
like that history because i don't think
the history between him and boba fett is
much stronger than him in fennick so i
think he's going to go for like i'm
going to kill someone that you love
pew pew yeah
that's the sound of my gut says cad bane
like magnitude pop-pop i'm sorry that's
a community reference here we go
he's not popping all right he's not
popping
he's not popping
i missed him um but no these are all
amazing theories but i think just
because i'm biased i'm going to give the
rogue point to whitney because i just
want to see
the the baby with his mommy again i want
to see them together again
it's just the way it's supposed to be
and like let's be real grogu is the
money maker
is why we watched mandatory and that's
why you gotta
get the temple to die because it's like
what you're gonna kill off the baby in a
luke skywalker kylo ren school shooting
no you're not no you're not that's
horrible no i if grogu dies that would
be
i just never watched the show again i'm
sorry to tell you guys i'm that yeah
yeah i would never watch
star wars again i would never forgive
them i would never forgive them but i
said it before we started give them i
said it before we started taping that
because
grosgu wasn't grogu is he's he's smart
we saw him jumping off rocks it takes a
lot of intelligence to jump from rock to
rock i guess i can't even
but he does
like the fact that ben straight up
destroys the temple
leads me to the fact that grogu isn't
there
yeah by the time that ben is at that
school so i don't think he's gonna
become a jedi he might do the thing also
there's nothing wrong with becoming tana
and just being like i don't respect not
she doesn't like the the faith of the
jedi anymore she lost faith in the jedi
so now she's just like i still do it but
i do it on my own terms but yeah i think
groku can still do the jedi stuff just
not with them it's just he needs to
learn how to balance like she does yeah
impossible i mean it it may very well
turn into a thing where he ends up
choosing to go with ahsoka for his
training and honestly honestly you know
yeah and then the sakutano the show is
just her and grogu bring him right back
oh my god who is the money
be
maker
like why can't why can't he do karate
and soccer different values we're a
soccer family and that's why whitney i
see you're bringing up our family
matters into this rogue theory but
there's one or just let me do karate i
always ask you and you won't let me
are are we gonna need to bring in that
uh sitcom piano music to have those
little sophomores moments listen whitney
i know you want to i know
you're a great kid whitney and someday
you can do that you can do all this
right now honey i need you to focus here
you're very special episoding me yeah
exactly rest in peace because you caught
me dealing spice mom and dad
oh shucks you got us but up next we're
going to talk about the winter soldier
possibly heading to a galaxy far far
away but first this week is one of your
last chances to get the boba inspired
latest obsession shirt over at
newrockstarsmerch.com
it's a really cool limited edition
design that they're about to send back
to the sarlacc pit for good so grab one
quick and check out all of our awesome
merch options over at
newrockstarsmerch.com but hey it's the
imperfections that make relationships
perfect matches they're always stealing
your fries when they could have ordered
their own or they take up way more than
50 of the bed which is you know not very
nice and you know tony stalker's
probably going full starfish in his bed
with pepper though but she loved them
anyway celebrate those imperfections
this valentine's day by getting your
partner some matching underwear match
your bottom half to your better half in
fun limited edition prints if you're
single mingle in matching pairs with
your friends or family and you can even
get dog hoodies or buddy bands to match
your four-legged friends which is even
better so be sure to check out all of me
undies super cute and super soft undies
socks loungewear and more available in
sizes extra small up to 4xl and me
undies has a great offer for our
listeners for a limited time only get 25
off your first order of matching pairs
for valentine's day and for a first time
purchaser you can also get 15 off and
free shipping right to your door so to
get 25 off matching pairs 15 off your
first order free shipping and a 100
satisfaction guarantee go to
meundies.com
rockstars that's meundies.com
rockstars and what would you do if you
didn't have high interest loans or
credit card debt move to a new city buy
a new car fill your living room with
funko pops like me don't do it girls
will never talk to you through upstart
you can pay off your existing debt
quickly with a personal loan so you can
tackle your big financial goal so
whether it's paying off credit cards
consolidating high interest debt or
funding of personal expenses over a
million people have used upstart to get
one fixed monthly payment with a clear
payoff date upstart knows that you're
more than just your credit score so
rather than looking at just that
upstart's model considers factors like
your income employment and other info
provided in your loan application to
find you a smarter rate so check out
your rate without impacting your credit
score in just five minutes for loans
between one thousand to fifty thousand
dollars and receive funds as fast as one
business day after accepting your loan
super quick so find out how upstart can
lower your monthly payments today when
you go to upstart.com
rogue that's upstart.com
rogue and do not forget to use our url
to let them know that we send you loan
amounts will be determined based on your
credit income and certain other
information provided in your loan
application let's go to upstart.com
rogue hey i know none of you watch not
safe for work content online i know
you're all good noodles but just in case
you have any friends that do that are
not you you might want to pay attention
to this because governments can use your
devices to track your location your
movements and in many countries your
internet activity oh my god your
searches are not as private as you think
one of the best ways to keep your online
browsing activity private is by using
expressvpn when you use expressvpn on
your phone computer or whatever your
internet connection is rerouted through
a secure encrypted server so you can
surf the web more anonymously without
anyone looking over your shoulder
because that's really creepy like you
remember that a brainy from uh from hey
arnold he was like
even in incognito mode your internet
provider can see every single website
that you visit that's weird and if you
live on campus or share wi-fi your
network administrator can too jesus this
is too much too much power that's why i
use expressvpn wherever i go online and
i recommend that all of you do the same
and with a single click of a button
expressvpn stops others from getting a
free license to peek over your shoulder
and see all the freaky content your
friend and not you are looking at so
protect your privacy today and get three
months of expressvpn for free by
visiting
com slash expressvpn.com that's e x p r
e s s v p n dot com slash r o
g u e for three months free with a one
year package visit expressvpn.com
rogue to learn more alright guys because
now that luke skywalker has played an
even larger role in the book of boba
fett after making a quick appearance in
the second season of the mandalorian it
makes us wonder could there be more and
what about the internet's favorite
choice to play the jedi master which
leads us to our second topic for today
could we see a luke skywalker spin-off
series like what would a spin-off
mini-series following luke skywalker
even look like because this week in a q
a with esquire sebastian stan finally
said never say never in regards to
playing luke skywalker something the
internet always seems to be clamoring
for because everyone loves sebastian
stan i mean he's the winner soldier he
cried in wakanda
he's crying about his feelings oh my god
so what
[Laughter]
so what would you like to see in a show
following the adventures of luke
skywalker and should it be sebastian
stan in that role i
all right
there's already a luke skywalker
spin-off and it's called a new hope
what they're gonna do is origin story
again
we already we already saw that i don't
need another one i know luke skywalker
he's being kind of a dick right now uh
okay that's the only thing that when i
read this i was like so you're asking
yourself like what haven't we seen him
in and also what do we want to see him
in and in my position i would love to
see the finished building of the luke
skywalker jedi school that is the only
part of luke skywalker i would want to
see left because i couldn't uh we could
be inquiring about seeing first off more
of the ant worker droids because i'm
very interested in what those are uh but
also we could see the young that's the
only reason like we could see the young
kylo ren and we could see the day-to-day
of kylo ren struggling but we could also
see the day-to-day to all the other kids
that were in the school we can find new
parts of star wars to be more attached
to and then we can still see like the
asakutano like cameos and people that
just come by the
the planet which are rare but
would i would like to just see the
school being made and how the first
couple years started out at the school
so we get more in depth of that that is
the only i would be i would be
interested to see that too but i do
think that in that circumstance i would
be
way more excited to see kylo ren
than i would be to see luke cause luke's
just kind of being an [ __ ] right now
this is what he is he's just [ __ ]
uncle luke at the moment
and uh i i do i do think that that if
they are gonna make one i agree with you
i think that that is gonna be the
context that they make it in and it will
be interesting oh but i just wonder
yeah yeah
because there's like anything else after
that would be just essentially a sequel
trilogy we've seen the sequel trilogy
already and how that story resolved with
with luke so in in any efforts the only
thing like jess said that's really there
to left for translation is that in
between
um
i mean the the only the only other thing
that i could think of could possibly be
could possibly be
the immediate time from the end of
return of the jedi up to the point where
he decides to start the school um
and and that's like that's like i think
college age i guess luke you know still
with his you know so and wild oats kind
of thing
however that pans out or whatever like
there's also that effort of recognizing
but i feel like that window is so
small
in terms of capitalizing on
you know oh and luke did this and luke
did that i mean
the only thing that i think
it could possibly do
with luke skywalker could be a possible
and mind you this is just a theory but
i know that there was a rumor back in
december for tales of the jedi that was
going about from like a gift to the
employees or whatever and there was a
little marquee thing for tales of the
jedi and i feel like the only other
effort that i could possibly believe
they could do with luke is if they took
legend stories
of luke skywalker in all the other
elements of where kind of think of
multiverse mindset
of
the storyline where luke became the next
darth vader the storyline where he got
married with mara the story line where
you know he goes i mean it would be
interesting if they did that kind of
swath and not a very large
series it could be something four
episodes five episodes but if you give
the opportunity to
really explore and celebrate that story
element because that's what dave fallon
is all about dave filoni took everything
that was legend and made it canon and
all the parts of it that are great like
admiral thrawn cad bane you bringing in
efforts of like you know agent fulcrum
all those parts that were part of the
story lines of fanfic they're all now
big parts of canon lore
and doing that would be really great to
make a sense where because let's be
honest rebels introduced uh time travel
so ever since that point pretty much
anything is possible within the star
wars universe and so these elements
could be like
fractal points kind of like the what if
if you will of star wars yeah i was just
gonna say i could [ __ ] with a luke
skywalker what if that'd be cool oh luke
i'd be into that that's good going i
just want to add for mine
really quick because you just reminded
me empty i think the idea of luke doing
the jedi school and the becoming of it
he is
what i would consider an [ __ ] right
now and he's in his [ __ ] phase but
we'd get more uh we get more of an
opening to understand him from his point
of view and his perspective because i
know his perspective but i'm not living
in his perspective and that's how like
we're so close when we were like fennick
might die we're close to fennick because
we've been with fenik this long if we
were with luke at this age for this long
in a new series we might learn to be
like oh i understand why you have to
choose between the mandalorian and the
jedi right out loud i vote i always root
for villains but i recognize that they
have different missions and different
values but i'm like you're being an
[ __ ] about it luke but i think if we
had a series for him i might believe
he's not and ask what what i really do
like about these episodes with luke
skywalker and grogu is that you know
it's sort of giving people uh it's it's
sort of making a case for the last jedi
and you know because luke was sort of
and that he sort of had that weird-ass
holiness there and he was like he was he
was so rigid in his belief in the jedi
code and so when yoda's just like you
know what we're destroying the books
we're destroying the house we don't need
any of this you're a big old jerk like
forget about religion just just feel the
force and you know just live your life
um i i love that moment in the last jedi
a lot because
me personally i think the jedi as a just
as an institution they're just not
really great in terms of life yeah
they're very not healthy
like when she recognized in the clone
wars that she got like
just like completely like t-boned i was
just like she was like no even though
you guys want me back i don't want to
come back you guys messed me up you guys
have you guys said you're for one thing
and you're not and i don't i don't want
to be in i don't want to be involved i
would literally go her around if i was a
jedi i'd be like i would i'm not going
to be with you guys i'm going to be on
my own
i'm going to hang out with me i'm going
to make [ __ ] float but you guys i'm
gonna make up yeah i'm still going to do
yoga but
i'm gonna do it over here
it's never worked out for a single jedi
to actually do the whole solitary life
thing yoda is like the only person that
that actually worked out for anakin got
messed up we later see obi-wan get
messed up when his crush gets murdered
it's like if you just let jedi
just let jedi let jedi have a girlfriend
seriously they would just be so much of
a balance
the balance it will be imbalanced and
then you're all evil that's that's
that's dumb and that's silly do you know
every time someone dies and let luke
skywalker no let him know exactly i
agree
as soon as someone dies they turn evil
yeah that is what happens when you have
a connection it happens to all of them
every time what is what does she say
she's a relationship
let's just just make sure that i had at
the right time valentine's day is coming
and you guys all need to hear this
exactly exactly do you ever think that
maybe they have toxic relationships with
these people because they're not allowed
to be with them and like it no exactly
they don't know they die
oh my god
all these days with this person i'm so
who have been in a school since they
were young and you expect them to learn
how to have a proper healthy
relationship when all they've been
learning is how to swing a stick and use
the brain exactly you know it's it's
well
it's it's also just basic human instinct
to find love and be loved but also and
it's not even that it's just a
connection and i recognize that but that
connection comes with a lot of other
emotions it's not just health it is also
just like it can be jealousy it can be
irritation it can be any of these things
and that can those little things can
offset the balance and that's why we
have kylo ren and so it's like and it's
so that's why i'm on board i'm not on
board i just recognize that i'm like you
have to be alone you have to be okay
with being like ostracized you have to
be okay with being alone because okay
with being alone but at the same time i
think that if somebody just can't be a
jedi
kylo ren maybe final final reason why he
would have said no because he was too
late
there should be no love amongst any jedi
is this the final example
rey
and kylo
that's the exact reason why there should
not be any levels because that whole
thing okay that's enough for me
they're going to reload territory
holding hands in their minds that's all
they wanted
let me just this is a mic you guys
osakatano said it in the mandalorian she
straight up said i know what happens
when there's too much love that's why
i'm not gonna train grogu because he
loves you too much and i've seen what
happens no one wants another anakin
no one wants another kylo ren nobody
needs those things in their life and
like rey is gonna be evil like rey is
gonna be evil
rey is gonna be evil she didn't wanna be
palpatine but she's gonna become
palpatine
i bet if before then her and kylo
you know did the beast with two backs
she would take the palpatine palpatine
name i'm just saying that would that's
the way that film would have probably
ended
look
come
[Music]
but no in regards to
the luke skywalker spin-offs here back
to the top right yeah okay yeah yeah
that's where we were supposed to be this
is what happens when you talk about star
wars though this is what happens when
you talk about star wars
this is what happens
it all reverts back to sex so it's okay
right it's that's i mean that's where
the galaxy comes from i mean duh i mean
um but no it's called the big bang for a
reason am i right fellas
exactly
but no i think that for me anyway i
would love to see a luke skywalker
spin-off series and like i've just been
clamoring for the return of samuel
jackson for forever but like samuel
jackson mace windu with luke skywalker i
don't know how this man would survive
but like i would love to see them team
up or like or just see see mace when to
appear in in the book of boba fett in
general but like seeing luke and mace
window team up would be a
a really sensible part of luke's journey
because mace wendy was all about the
jedi and he was all about the stringent
rules and so i feel like he would try to
learn from a mace windu and she would be
like oh yeah what's up like what's so
great about the jedi and let's absorb
all that but like you know maybe miss
windu is um jaded
maybe that's not the right word maybe
james windu just doesn't really like the
jedi anymore because anakin chopped his
arm off he's like you know what screw
all this and i hate you
son and i'm gonna punch you in the face
um
so comes over here just goes over top
tells luke hey he goes
luke go get my lightsaber because which
one is it it's the one that says bad
[ __ ]
i was just gonna say if they bring him
back to the star wars universe they have
to let him call someone a [ __ ] they
have to
have to let him tell
a character that they look like a [ __ ]
preferably jar jar
or or in the star wars jargon like
you know
does he look like a nerf herder yeah
does he look like in there
yeah
does marcellus wallace look like a nerf
herder
calories
i love it
but no these are all amazing answers per
usual you guys are so smart i want to
give the rogue point to jess for the
whole idea of seeing the school star
because we see that in you know the
sequel trilogy and like i've always
wanted to see how the knights of ren
even started up and like you know all
this whole look because like it is in a
jedi academy was very much teased in the
legends canon it was a huge part of
legends canon so like i would love to
see that
just play out in the the new canon so
have your point jess
i don't know how to play guitar
i think
but now it is time for our rogue
question because during an interview
this week chan and tatum revealed some
information about the scrapped gambit
film he's been producing including the
fact that it would be more like a
romantic comedy so knowing this
pitch me your rogus romantic comedy
starring the mutant gambit i did not
know that it was going to be a romantic
comedy i like slightly another day yeah
i don't know if that's a good idea
yeah wait a minute i mean you got the
raging cajun there in
in
marvel lore and
the only thing i could possibly think of
is if like
gambit and rogue decide to go and try to
have a normal night on the town
and it turns into like a uh that date
night kind of thing like i feel like
that could be the only way it could be
like a romantic comedy kind of thing uh
because honestly i when i think when i
think of gambit i don't really think
romantic comedy uh but i mean hey you
know
that's that's what i mean like um
channing tatum does have those chops to
to do a romantic comedy so i'm sure it
would have worked though i'm not sure if
it would it would have been perfect for
the character again bit i don't know it
would just be really weird
that's all i got
okay all right i dig it like a date
night type scenario right i think that
they should uh they should just remake
magic mike but with x-men
and i think that we should see uh gambit
you know like doing like a really sexy
strip tease but as he's doing it you
know like as he's tossing off his
clothes he's also tossing playing cards
left and right getting real yeah getting
real fancy with it and then the best
part would be when like rogue comes up
on stage and she like takes off her
glove and everyone thinks it's gonna be
like a sexy thing but then she's like
back gotcha and like gets them and kills
them that's what i want to see
magic might give you i like these rogue
theories these x with with rogue in them
um but yeah no i yeah i dig it a lot i
think jess is like
i'm trying to think of uh
of um channing tatum movies uh to
overlap because i think realistically
realistically i think eddie is correct
is probably what he was gonna do i what
do i want what do the what do the people
want what whitney said um
what they want
i'm gonna say that it's gonna be like uh
yeah oh
baby
i would go
immediately but i think it's gonna be
like now you see me the movie that
doesn't have channing tatum in it but
this time it does and it's gambit and
the whole team oh my god people from the
x-men series that would be great yo
they were all just you know i think that
that that fits well the magic part is
all about cars
yeah woody harrelson's
yeah it's like it's basically it's the
same movie and woody harrelson's there
but gambit is there instead of jesse
eisenberg yes 100 i like it i really
really like that
you know what i think i'm gonna have to
give you the wrong point for that one
because i really i really like the now
you see me movies in general i think
they're kind of like underrated even
though they're not you know they're not
like a huge cinema but like i just think
they're just fun it's a fun time so i
would love to see a gamut movie in the
vein of now you see me wow you like now
you see me more than you like magic mike
that's
wild um
did you even see magic mike empty i
haven't seen the met i don't know my
magic mike lore yet but i'm gonna get
into oh my gosh you don't know magic
mike lore okay well i'm gonna put
together
we'll get you a vision board of magic
mike maybe in a blue screen you'll see
me dress like channing
that's right anyway i guess that'd be
weird um i think this makes jessica i
mean even though all of your theories
were amazing as always i think this is
my guitar our winner for today
six solos
you guys are all winners because you
guys are some of the smartest people on
star wars on the internet i'm saying
that right now i'm making a definitive
statement you guys are not not me i
don't don't come from here
are you watching dave these three
beautiful people but that is it for this
episode of rogue theory thanks to our
guests jessica clemons whitney van
lenningham and eddie villanueva support
all of their stuff follow them on
twitter first of all they're all amazing
people and also you can support our
channel by checking out all of our
awesome merch over at new
rockstarsmerch.com and if you have got
thoughts about some of our rogue
theories you can share them on our
discord if you're over 18 click the link
in the new rockstars discord server in
the description and join the
conversation because we would love to
have you join our game nights too
because we play lots of fun little games
on jetbox and all sorts of things we
have fun conversations so discord new
rockstars come get it um follow me on
masterchairman if you want to see me
tweet some weird [ __ ] follow new
rockstars wherever we are on social
media and be sure to subscribe to our
channel here on youtube and hit that
notification bell so you get
notifications every time we upload a
video i said a lot of words thank you
guys so much for joining us this episode
we love you guys so much and uh
i'll see you guys next time
[Music]
you